[Music]
presidential campaign in full swing now
everybody's out there stumping everybody
they've got all hands on deck in a
speech today Vice President Joe Biden
said the following he said I promise you
the president has a big stick that's
what he said in a related story to a
Biden is now banned from the
Congressional gym locker room a new
Republican I just came out that claims
that President Obama is now too focused
on being cool yeah
President Obama hasn't responded to the
ad because he's too busy snowboarding
with the boy band One Direction
[Music]
some good news for Mitt Romney did you
hear this yesterday Texas Governor Rick
Perry endorsed Mitt Romney for president
yeah
Perry Perry said Perry said he chose
Romney because out of the one candidate
left he's the best speaking of this a
college student has launched a group
called african-americans for Romney yeah
although after a couple days he was
forced to change the name to that black
guy for Romney
[Applause]
this interesting today is bring your
kids to work day did you know that bring
your kids to work day yeah or as it's
known at the iPad Factory in China bring
your parents to work day there goes my
free iPad did you hear this a a doctor
announced just announced that he has at
long last found the female g-spot
however as he made the announcement at
the press conference his wife stood
behind him shaking her head now
[Applause]
this crazy the Census Bureau reports
that the number of interracial couples
has increased over 40 percent since 2000
the the most common couplings are black
and white white and Hispanic an NBA
player and Kardashian
[Applause]